all right let me get to Joe Buck Fox NFL
baseball play-by-play announcer where
are you Joe I'm sitting in my damn desk
where I've been for the last 2 damn
weeks describe the office the office
they're taking inventory for me a lot of
pictures of myself that's kind of the
way I roll me in various poses me with
with friends that I haven't kept up here
over the years there some pictures of my
wife in here there's one picture of my
kids that's irrelevant there's a bunch
of Amy's sitting around there's two
bobbleheads
there's a lot of books that I've told
people that I've read and haven't the
one thing you grab if you can only grab
one thing leaving in the house Emmys all
of them
me too yeah yeah now I was the one thing
I would grab there's a picture I mean I
figure you know if I'm running out of
the house I'm running out of the house
with my wife and kids so we can replace
those pictures but there's a picture of
my dad in me that I joke about the Emmys
for a lot of different reasons but there
was one night we had New York where he
got a lifetime Emmy and I got to present
him and there we and I are sharing a hug
that there's a look on both of our faces
that I would never want to lose and was
taken with one of those disposable
cameras that we bought at the Marriott
on the way and somehow the picture
actually turned out so that that
definitely would be something that I
would search for in the smoke and by the
way I'm talking as somebody whose moms
house burned to the ground so I it's you
do lose a lot and whatever doesn't get
burned gets drowned so it's it's it's
not a laughing matter but I would
definitely go after that picture how are
you keeping sharp I don't know that I've
ever been sharp fair I dunno yeah I am
we are
I would assume you're in the same boat
as me I'm
I'm really flooded with information with
daily clips that Fox has some service
it'll pull clips from every newspaper in
the country or different blogs or
different websites or whatever they're
kind of consolidates the different
baseball stories of different football
stories newsletters whatever I get
online and I actually I feel like I'm
kind of more dialed in and I've ever
been there's just nothing to do with the
information but I've done probably more
reading in my quote-unquote offices and
then I've been I've ever done because
I'm sitting around the house and trying
to duck away from my almost two year old
twin boys what have you heard about
baseball I really haven't heard anything
I don't know that anybody knows any real
information I would imagine if you sat
down with Rob Manfred right now the
Commissioner Major League Baseball he
would have no real idea of when they're
going to get going I mean they went in
and maybe if III would like to think
that there's going to be a season I
would like to think that if they got 80
81 games in Mike a fasces and it would
feel like a major league baseball effort
but I think anything short of that you
know they're good they're gonna have to
get rolling in my opinion by at least
mid June
I don't see May as a possibility and
they're basically going to have to start
spring training over again whenever they
ramp up I mean all this dust seems silly
when you think about loss of life in
this whole pandemic situation that is
literally around the world so I get it
when people roll their eyes and you're
talking about sports but it's a big part
of American life and you know I've
talked to our producer with golf the US
Open is mid-june I would say that's iffy
and and even if they do play it or even
if they do get back to baseball who
knows what the crowd situations gonna be
like so it's a brave new world a totally
different world and I don't know that
anybody can tell you and nobody at the
network is that one word about when
baseball will start up nobody knows but
we're going to be so backed up with all
these sporting events if
look at golf baseball starts the NBA if
they try to squeeze that in NASCAR try
to get that in there's hockey that needs
to be squeezed in here maybe soccer that
needs to be squeezed in then you start
with the offseason workouts or training
camp with the NFL I don't know if we
have enough time to put all of that in
in the span of about you know five
months yeah I know I agree with you I
know from a reliable source that at
least with regard to hockey their plan
is you know first of all they've been
need to make sure nobody tests positive
you know whenever the start update is
looming and then they'll have a camp for
about a week they'll open up the
playoffs to even more teams and they
typically have and I think they'll just
slam right into a playoff situation and
play the and play the Stanley Cup
Playoffs
so I there's no way they can finish the
regular season
readjust go into the playoffs and I
think it's going to be that way across
the board I don't know what Major League
Baseball is going to do with a shortened
season and maybe they have to or get to
toy with the postseason picture and add
teams like they floated a month or so
ago and the postseason looks different
not only in 2020 but going forward maybe
it's an opportunity that way to get
people looking at the playoffs in a
different way than they ever have in
Major League Baseball talking to Joe
Buck Fox NFL baseball play-by-play
announcer he has been inviting fans to
send him videos so he can call
play-by-play and you said on Twitter you
did about 12 videos yesterday do you do
you want to ask for more here today oh
yeah I mean I they're stacked up okay
trust me but I'm happy to get him and I
want to keep doing them what what I
didn't realize was I got these videos
Fox compiled them for me because I'm
just it has nothing to do with with
anything but my technological ineptitude
and they sent me the videos
I did the voiceover into kind of a
portable recording device and then I
sent those files back to somebody at Fox
and then they're putting him on top of
the videos and then I got a note last
night what we're trying to clear the
videos I guess with the people who sent
them so yeah they'll they'll start you
know hitting the Internet today I you
know I don't want everybody to like hold
their breath like these are the you know
this is Michelangelo presenting
play-by-play of somebody throwing darts
in their living room but it did those
are done I'd like to do 10 or 12 a day
just for the hell of it and people seem
to enjoy it
hopefully they do if they don't I'll
stop if they do I think it's it's a
chance to maybe raise some money for
people who desperately need it at this
time of total shutdown and what are you
asking for from those who send in videos
I just did the donation somewhere I mean
I have no way of following up on it I
think I'm just playing on people's guilt
playing on people's you know their word
and hoping that they'll follow through
on what they say they'll do if I do the
play-by-play too whatever they're doing
in their backyard their living room
their basement or whatever it might be
then they've got to make a donation
somewhere that matters during this time
and and I don't care if it's ten
thousand dollars ten dollars or $1 just
I think the effort gets everybody
thinking the right way so I'm not
checking up on it I'm just hoping that
people will actually follow through on
making good because I you know we you
you and I are so lucky to do what we do
and there's so many people wondering if
they're going to be able to make you
know a rent check or wondering where the
next paycheck is going to come from or
when so I you know any little bits got
to help where the kids I have no idea
they're you know they're rather they're
wandering the halls they turn to at the
end of April Michelle my wife is sitting
with them right now they're coloring and
then my other kids my
other set the 23 and 20 year olds are
all ones home from New York one zone
from USC and everybody's together so I
mean I think there's some silver lining
in it obviously while people are you
know struggling with this virus
you know those who aren't touched by it
personally I think have an opportunity
to reconnect and I think that's it's
been nice having everybody at home but I
have never wanted to go pay somebody for
a dinner out more than I do right now
rank your kids because you told me this
privately like favorite to least
favorite yeah well I I mean they're two
different sets there's the older set and
then the younger set the younger of the
older two she and I have a connection
but the older one the trick in parenting
in in my 23 years of it excuse me is
making both feel like they're the
favorite kid so I I think they both if
you hooked him up to a lie detector and
you said are you your dad's favorite kid
they would both say yes and they would
both pass so you know I I don't think
publicly is the right time to do it at a
bar I'll tell you which one is my
favorite and then of the younger two one
of them looks a lot like me bigger head
is that a good thing your body no you
got it all beautiful life I I feel bad
for that but the other one no they're
both you know they're both knock on wood
and thank god they're both you know
good-looking kids but one looks like my
baby picture one looks like Michelle's
baby picture so I'll let you guess which
one of those two Evans and through
almost two years of life is my favorite
ah good luck at home there enjoy all of
that can we do this you want to call it
later you want to call in tomorrow
because as soon as your wife doesn't
hear you on the radio anymore you just
pretend you're talking I yeah you just
hang up whatever you're yes and I'll
just
get a really loud volume and she'll
think it up still I'm still doing it
[Music]
give me a fun with Dan Patrick get a
fake laugh in there too
there you go
and that'll always do yeah you don't
want to interrupt that by the time you
and thousand four good times great
oldies yeah good luck Joe I'm a long
time okay yeah you uh you have a great
day thank you Joe that's Joe Buck Fox
NFL baseball play-by-play announcer